and get 2 months free.
>> Tucker: WITHOUT QUESTION
THE MOST DOMINANT PLAYER IN THE
HISTORY OF FINAL EXAM IS
FOX NEWS AT NIGHT ANCHOR
SHANNON BREAM.
AT LAST SHE WAS UNLEASHED ON OUR
HAPLESS BOX STAFF.
SHE COLLECTED NINE IN A ROW
BEFORE THE RAMPAGE FINALLY CAME
TO AN END THANKS TO
LELAND VITTERT.
THAT WAS A SHOWDOWN.
HERE ARE SOME HIGHLIGHTS.
>> Tucker: AMAZON THE COMPANY
JUST ANNOUNCED AN INTERESTING
NEW SERVICE.
FOR A FEE YOU CAN HAVE YOUR
DELIVERY DRIVER DO WHAT WITH
YOUR AMAZON PACKAGE?
SHANNON BREAM.
>> TAKE THEM INSIDE YOUR HOUSE.
>> Tucker: I DON'T BELIEVE
THAT, IT'S TOO WEIRD.
BUT WE WILL SEE IF YOU ARE RIGHT
ON OUR TAPE.
>> TECH TITAN AMAZON IS TAKING
THINGS A FEW STEPS FARTHER,
LITERALLY, DELIVERING THOSE
PACKAGES NOT JUST TO YOUR
DOORSTEP, BUT INSIDE YOUR HOME.
IT'S CALLED AMAZON KEY.
>> Tucker: HOW DID YOU KNOW
THAT?
>> I'VE BEEN WATCHING THE NEWS
PROGRAMMING >> Tucker: WOULD
YOU LET AMAZON INTO YOUR HOME?
>> HACK TO THE KNOW.
>> Tucker: ON SUNDAY NIGHT
WITH FORMER U.S.
PRESIDENT THROUGHOUT THE FIRST
PITCH AT THE WORLD SERIES GAME
IN HOUSTON, TEXAS.
WHO WAS IT?
>> BUSH 43.
>> Tucker: AS DISTINCT FROM
41.
TO THE TAPE WE GO.
>> 43 TAKING THE FIELD IN
HOUSTON WHERE HE IS GREETED BY
HIS FATHER, FORMER
PRESIDENT GEORGE H.W. BUSH.
HE GAVE THEM THE BALL.
IF SUCH AN AMAZING SIGHT, TWO
PRESIDENTS ON THE SAME DIAMOND
AND THEN PRESIDENT BUSH WINDING
UP AND THROWING A STRIKE, OF
COURSE.
>> HAVE YOU TESTED THESE LIGHTS?
>> Tucker: PRESIDENT TRUMP WAS
EMBROILED IN A CONTROVERSY
DURING HIS STOP IN JAPAN THIS
WEEK.
SOME CALLED IT A FAKE
CONTROVERSY.
HE WAS BLASTED FOR DUMPING ALL
BOX OF FOOD INTO WHICH KIND OF
ANIMAL ENCLOSURE?
SHANNON BREAM.
>> A KOI POND.
>> Tucker: A KOI POND!
NOT A LLAMA ENCLOSURE, A KOI
POND.
TO THE TAPES.
>> LATER MR. TRUMP FEEDING ASIAN
CARP AT A KOI POND.
FIRST TOSSING SPOONFULS OF FISH
FOOD FOR EMPTYING THE ENTIRE
BOX.
>> THAT WAS THE GREATEST VIDEO.
HE'S LIKE FORGET IT, YOU ARE
GETTING EVERYTHING.
>> Tucker: THAT WAS SO GOOD.
DID YOU KNOW IT WAS A KOI POND?
>> I KNEW THE ANSWER BUT I CAN'T
GET IN HERE.
>> Tucker: A RETURNING
CHAMPION LEADS ONCE AGAIN.
THIS COURT 2-1.
I WANT TO CONGRATULATE YOU.
THE WINNER OF THE MOUTH
BREATHING MUG.
>> IT IS MY HONOR.
>> Tucker: SARAH HUCKABEE
SANDERS WAS UNDER SCRUTINY OVER
THANKSGIVING VACATION.
SHE SHARED A PHOTOGRAPH ON
SOCIAL MEDIA OF A DISH SHE HAD
MADE AT HOME BUT AT LEAST ONE
REPORTER SAID IT LOOKED TOO GOOD
TO BE REAL AND ACCUSED HER OF
THINKING THAT DISH.
WHAT FOOD DID SHE MAKE?
>> PECAN PIE.
>> Tucker: TO THE TAPE WE GO.
>> WEISS DORMANT WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY UNDER FIRE THIS
WEEKEND AFTER SHE POSTED A
PICTURE OF THIS PIE SHE SAID SHE
BAKED IT.
>> SHE'S BEEN MAKING THIS PIE
FOR YEARS.
DON'T EVER MESS WITH A SOUTHERN
WOMAN AND HER HOMEMADE PIE.
>> Tucker: SHANNON BREAM.
TO EACH OTHER, STARTING TO
UNDERSTAND THE KEY TO THIS GAME.
YOU ARE LIGHTNING FAST.
>> CATLIKE REFLEXES.
X49ers PLAYER COLIN KAEPERNICK
WAS JUST PRESENTED THE COVETED
MUHAMMAD ALI LEGACY AWARD DURING
A "SPORTS ILLUSTRATED" SPORTS
AWARD CEREMONY.
WHICH FAMOUS PERSON, A SINGER,
PRESENTED HIM WITHOUT A WORD
SAYING "HE HAS A SELFLESS HEART
HEART."
>> BEYONCE!
>> Tucker: BEYONCE SAYS
SHANNON BREAM.
TO THE TAPE WE GO.
>> LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, I'M SO
PROUD AND HUMBLED TO PRESENT THE
COLIN KAEPERNICK.
>> I ACCEPT THIS AWARD KNOWING
THAT THE LEGACY OF MUHAMMAD ALI
IS THAT OF A CHAMPION OF THE
PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: THANK YOU BOTH.
SHANNON, YOUR RAIN REMAINS IN
PLACE.
ANOTHER MOUTH BREATHING MODE.
>> ANY TIME YOU COME OVER FOR
DINNER.
>> Tucker: YOU DID BETTER THAN
ANY OTHER COMPETITOR AGAINST
SHANNON BREAM.
>> I ANSWERED ONE QUESTION.
>> BUT CORRECTLY.
>> Tucker: FINAL QUESTION.
DISNEY HAS UNVEILED ITS NEW
ROBOT VERSION OF THE PRESIDENT
OF THE UNITED STATES,
DONALD TRUMP.
IT'S IN THE HALL OF PRESIDENTS
EXHIBIT IN THE MAGIC KINGDOM.
THERE'S A PROBLEM THOUGH.
MANY SAY THE ROBOT LOOKS NOTHING
LIKE THE PRESIDENT BUT LIKE
WHICH ACTOR INSTEAD?
SHANNON BREAM.
>> JOHN BOYD.
>> Tucker: THAT'S A WEIRD
GUESS.
IF YOU GET THIS RIGHT YOU WIN.
TO THE TAPE.
>> SOME OF THE INTERNET SAY IT
LOOKS LIKE A BLOATED JOHN BOYD.
HE'S NEVER GOING TO SPEAK TO ME
AGAIN.
>> LOOK AT THAT!
>> Tucker: SHANNON BREAM
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN.
YOU WIN.
THIS WEEK WE HAVE A SMALL BOTTLE
OF NONALCOHOLIC CHAMPAGNE THAT
WE ARE GOING TO GIVE YOU.
>> DO I GET TO SPRAY IT?
>> Tucker: IT TAKES A LOT LIKE
BUBBLY WATER BUT IT'S DELICIOUS.
WHICH SENATOR ANNOUNCED HE IS
RETIRING THIS YEAR, POSSIBLY
PAVING THE WAY FOR MITT ROMNEY
TO RUN FOR HIS SEAT?
SHANNON BREAM.
>> ORRIN HATCH.
>> Tucker: THAT CAN'T BE
RIGHT.
ORRIN HATCH RETIRING?
I DON'T BELIEVE IT.
I THINK IT'S CHRIS DODD.
>> THE LONGEST-SERVING
REPUBLICAN SENATOR ORRIN HATCH
WILL NOT SEEK REELECTION THIS
YEAR.
THE LAWMAKER FROM UTAH
ANNOUNCING HIS RETIREMENT AFTER
SERVING SINCE 1977.
>> Tucker: DON'T FEEL BAD.
>> I DON'T.
>> Tucker: YOU GET OUR AIRPLAY
SIZE CHAMPAGNE.
IT'S DELICIOUS.
CHRIS STIREWALT, YOU REALLY WERE
A WORTHY OPPONENT.
LAST WEEK SHE COMPLETED A FULL
BRADY BUNCH BEATING
CHRIS STIREWALT TO RUN HER
KNACKERED STOMACH RECORD TO 9-0.
TONIGHT SHE GOES FOR TEN
STRAIGHT WIN AGAINST AMERICA'S
NEWS HEADQUARTERS HOST
LELAND VITTERT.
A MAN FAMOUS FOR HIS NEWS
ACUITY.
THE PRESIDENT JUST UNVEILED HIS
LATEST NICKNAME, THIS TIME FOR
SENATOR DIANNE FEINSTEIN OF
CALIFORNIA.
WHAT WAS THAT NICKNAME?
WAS IT SLEEPY DIANE, SNEAKY
DIANE, SWAMPY DIANE?
LELAND VITTERT.
>> I'M GOING WITH SNEAKY.
>> Tucker: SNEAKY DIANE.
NOT SWAMPY, SNEAKY.
NOT SLEEPY.
WELL TAPE.
>> WE DO HAVE THIS TWEET LAST
HOUR.
WHAT WAS IT, 20 MINUTES AGO?
THE FACT THAT SNEAKY DIANE
FEINSTEIN -- SNEAKY DIANE
FEINSTEIN.
HERE WE GO.
LOOK OUT SLOPPY STEVE.
SNEAKY DIANNE FEINSTEIN.
>> HE'S TRYING TO LO MEIN.
>> Tucker: THIS IS WITHOUT
PRESIDENT.
>> CAN I HAND IT OVER?
>> Tucker: YES YOU CAN.
THIS IS THE COVETED MOUTH ME THE
MUG.
IT GOES TO YOU, MR. AMERICA.
>> I'M GRACIOUS FOR YOU AND YOUR
UNBELIEVABLE --
>> YOU NEED TO BORROW THE OTHER
NINE, I'M HAPPY TO DO IT.
IT GOT TO BE PREPARED FOR
ANYTHING.
>> Tucker: CONGRATULATIONS TO
YOU.
SHANNON BREAM YOU HAVE BEEN A
FIERCE COMPETITOR, A TERRIFYING
COMPETITOR, CONGRATULATIONS.
>> Tucker: NOTHING IN THIS
LIFE LASTS FOREVER, EVEN A